maintenant nous arrivons au climax de
cette émission est là messieurs c'est le
blind test
un blind test ce soir en hommage à
charles trenet donc nous entendrons des
reprises de chansons de charles trenet
par d'autres interprètes amer est ce que
je vous demanderai à vous tous ici c'est
de me donner les interprètes bien
entendu parce que les titres des
chansons les connaît oui mais d'abord
pour animer et arbitrer ce blind test
match au filet pourquoi les îles par
dessus et le soleil
tout n'est pas parfait mais l'essentiel
c'est quoi ces deux modèles soit bien
alors comment ça va se passer je pense
que je vais pleurer super cool y est
haïtien ah ben oui quand il est arrivé
donc est-ce qu'on peut mettre un tout le
monde ah oui mais manua et on a joué ce
soir non puisque c'est charles trenet le
soleil qui avait rendez vous avec la
lune
d'accord ça te plait ça tire et ça me
plaît beaucoup jusqu'ici tout va bien je
trouve tes amis franchement alors gina
qui est une jeune sur place et nadia qui
l'a bien voilà et voilà mieux bien alors
attention à mon étoile sol et ici c'est
le soleil a rendez vous avec la lune
hard ou à du très bien philips est
parfait jusqu'ici on commence didier
premières chansons
vous avez vous avez dit eddy mitchell et
vous avez des côtes françois et vous
avez tous raison parce qu'effectivement
c'est eddy mitchell et que prend toi
donc à partir donc un partout pour
invoquer un point ici là nous sommes
deuxième chanson dédiée
poutine
mechiche méchas
et toi que moi
les charges
ras du montant investi voici les
oh là là là on soutient olalala venait à
peine si j'ai crié mais si vous appelez
comment première fois trois essais ce
soit joli mouvement initié ce qui lui
plaît attention attention attention
marie gillain signé serge est ce qu'on
veut faire un petit rythme s'il vous
plaît
content
tu verrais ça nous a permis de nous
connaître en même temps bravo le
contrôle vidéo tel geste
bravo donc ça fait en année ou sur les
points là deux plis de la m2a et les
mène par deux points les basques on se
fait engueuler brad wall a très bien
bien
alors didier chanson il est au point la
chine a un nom le nom des bons jours
bien bien
égalité bah oui tu as une vraie culture
à cultiver bien on continue une
quatrième
medawala
c
bien très bien la chanson numéro 5
il a tout ça
il y eut un matin
bompard
ap
bon maintenant maintenant c'est pas dans
le comté juste pour voir comme ça ces
enjeux les deux camps mais maintenant
c'est passé très compliqué je vous
envoie juste les écouter oui quatre
versions de la merde
allez prénom il a le même prénom et
français vous connaissez savuth
incroyable vous appelez comment la
bravoure mx est une star six sur dix à
la six
moi
y'a des joueurs
et
jadis elle
mais dans l'est
c'était plusieurs pays en plusieurs
temps
ouais
pour l'économie mais les forces des
connards de cinéma ah c'est vous les
regardez surtout on connaît les charlots
et combien il gagne la liga c'est lui
n'a comme ils sont là trois pour les
soleils et 4 pour les lunes chance
qu'elle mes recettes didier très
compliqué
le travail
très compliqué c'est un brésilien quitte
le gouvernement
chaque acteur gilbert toro bravo tu top
10 est très peu connu pourquoi j'ai
l'air un peu moi quelle musique tu veux
des écoutes
c'est vrai dire on lui fait un
compliment est pourquoi je m ennuie
nantes
non non non non c'est là d'ailleurs
c'est génial zhao site berthod bravo
alors maintenant chanson numéro 8 didier
combis
j'en reviens pas
georges mois l'âge que vous connaissez
ça ouais la boîte si votre papa écouter
s'annonce en france et qui fait régner
la lune comme ça didier je voudrais
qu'on passe à la chanson numéro 10
mon temps
l'entrée québécois elle belge même si
vous trouviez ça c'est aussi maintenant
là si vous trouvez ça vous êtes fort dj
mais voilà la petite chanson là qui
vient dans le dit cela
c'est miharu cauchy la berthenoux
connais ça vraiment je crois qu'elle
béatrice qui venait ça oui pour
l'instant à égalité à l'année ou égalité
parfaite au salon va arriver au super
banco alors attention super banco didier
de france d'euros
très dur j'ai mis au vert
ce qu'ils voulaient et
moi
oui
on va
non
pourtant les hommes de retrouver quand
même les murs de tous nous retrouver par
le titre du groupe i la lune
jamais titré durement franchement j'ai
très dur ce sont les tueurs de la lune
de miel à la à qui la ville avait alors
t'as pas vu ben dhia bien camarades d'un
mélo cette norme et tu l'avais dit
vraiment oui c'est bien et comment tu
les connais et si les bons chanteurs
coups de bras merci beaucoup merci à
tous
c'était donc une égalité parfaite voilà
c'était tout le monde en parle lombalgie
sexe magouille culture générale une
pièce de l'homme ainsi avec la batterie
pascal sellem mado maurin dans percy et
j'ai hâte d'y mener des rats au théâtre
du gymnase louis islandaise entraîneur
de l'egypte et du psg
mathilde seigner à la fiche du film de
claude miller la chambre des magiciennes
le 28 février
avec anne brochet à lui noël et jacques
faudel sortie de l'album de poubelles
samra quitteront promo lilas à l'olympia
le 11 mai marie gillain à la fiche du
film de bruno chiche
barnie et ses petites contrariétés avec
nathalie baye fabrice luchini et ibos
pire
gilles ménage l'oeil du pouvoir face au
terrorisme et moyen-orientales 1981-1986
aux éditions fayard keaton en tournée à
partir du 1er mars
christine ockrent la double vide hillary
clinton
c'est robert laffont michel desjoyeaux
qui a remporté le vendée globe est un
amant mais malraux quant à la barre du
prb et jean rappelle la sortie du film
de jean michel bernard jetons le match
idée brouillé avec anthony delon que
direct du feuilletage jean michel
bernard et patrick chesnais voilà
c'était tout le monde en parle
l'émission pas comme les jo rendez vous
la semaine prochaine